sabe o que faz o splitter com o céu o
inter céu e não não não é mesmo só
porque eu também tenho alguns críticos
não
olá a todos pessoal aqui quem fala é o
dar que seja muito bem vindo já é mais
um vídeo e o estrago seguir o pixel rico
é um jogo para óculos fifa e pelo que
parece ser eu acho que é um jogo que tem
vários minigames dentro deu eu ainda não
entendi não experimentei nada espera
espera que eu tenho trip ada o que é que
o senhor gosta mais de fazer nos tempos
livres falará o cell phone não é
desculpa
o ato foi quando é que eu estou o uso de
bênção da manhã consegui ver as minhas
uma borboleta amiga não vai passar a
ganhar em é muito mais suave botafogo
contribuir na zona lyon caiu soube
explicar basicamente o meu porque raio é
que nós temos um gameboy à frente deu o
sim ou o não gosta que ela nos passar
tudo escuro u 8 dentro de uma sala de
aula meu por isso mesmo que eu tô
escolas e óculos rio terminal coisa que
poderia ter inventado o um golpe
parabéns pelo cae não existe como eu
quero acertar apenas a entrada não a ama
e fucking dólares de outubro tal costa
lá eu tenho uma professora
agora a cabeça
desculpa ela filma eu tô usar uma saia
meu o que quer dizer que o wii super
ligeiro ou então uma menina
sei que no meu ombro a tropa que não tem
cabeça isto é mentira e não tanto foi
que impede isso comigo e que me amam
eu não sei o que aconteceu o pessoal
mais de mil epic mickey eo por isso ela
ficará agora fora do sítio
o que não tira país amigos eu sou da
nossa turma avós não podem fazer essas
coisas pega vou tentar acertar alliance
estão a tentar em estágio também vou
tentar vou conseguir fotografar com a
fuga de um castigo tomou lá de lançar
meu batom reflexo ao acaso é maluco meu
deus da janela tokyo preste atenção
neste professora que contratar um gás da
janela tipo não fazer nada não tá é
presentemente eu tenho aqui um gameboy
nas mãos mas não conseguiu
só que que buscará para trás por
conseguir ver ok
o hotel foi que eu consegui chegar aqui
tudo mesmo chegar pessoas que estão em
uma animação e do mesmo ficar com o
teclado e rato que nunca embora eu
escutar foquem épico só não sei que jogo
é esse
hoje parece ser típico ou um super mario
o falsificado é desculpa
ela bateu a mesa ela tá maluca meu tá
maluca desculpa professora
a aae saber como foi o golpe é tão
grande tão grande desculpa pensar em
mover sua opinião não é porque o pessoal
vamos tentar outra vez pelos 20
professora não pode apanhar a fazer
estas coisas não diz para falar enquanto
professora estava lá né
nada e querem é bem bacana
ah eu tava explicar que consigo acertar
ali mas já fiz isso há pouco caía agora
vamos focar aqui o tom da cama desculpa
amigo a falei meu tempo se acertaram e
calma calma calma e ela perguntou não
fui eu foi foi causar manoel alencar é
uma menina com a preciosa
eu vou aproveitar agora que a professora
estava de costas para jogar aqui uma em
goiânia ela não conseguiu
ela quase não viu nada a professora pode
vir através taxava é e você começar de
novo a culpa ou o saturn muitas moedas
aqui meu eu quero o que está a passar o
que está a passar é que nem eu sei eu
não o odeio perder seu lugar o piloto já
na folha de são paulo que tem que fazer
diz para manu diz para valente para
praticar a gente para obrigar o painel
domingo faz isto eu acho que tem que
usar a caneta é isso mesmo serviço
isso isso isso
mata a sua mãe também falei meu deus
muito rápida meu lar faz tempo que
mataria bolsa
estamos fazendo aqui é difícil isso era
só mais um pouquinho lá o poder do papel
que falei e falei que o papel não era o
momento do botafogo não conseguia
acreditar nisso o psol que embora eu
facilito zelda e uma mulher guerreira um
after effects aquino mail mas só quem
gosta de tomar drogas também tomar
drogas
o drogba estrela epsilon play off e
vamos ficar por aqui com espírito só
espero mesmo que vocês tenham gostado
deste jogo tava funk em oz chama sério é
dura aí vocês sempre tem uma
oportunidade de experimentar alguns hits
por mim porque falo mesmo a pena e é
esse pessoal deixe você publique
favorito fiquem bem a prova